so who's my guest this week it's the
courtroom artist jane rosenberg
since 1946 broadcasts and photographs of
criminal proceedings inside u.s federal
courts has been strictly banned
no matter how notorious the accused or
headline grabbing the crime media
cameras are kept out
instead it is left to the artist to be
the eyes of the public and capture the
drama of the courtroom
for the past 40 years jane rosenberg has
come face to face with those involved in
some of america's most high profile
cases
she sketched everyone from el chapo to
harvey weinstein and her drawings have
been seen all over the world
[Music]
from the new york courts filled with mob
bosses to those accused in the metoo era
she has seen it all so what is it like
drawing gelane maxwell jeffrey epstein
and bill cosby here's what's coming up
the now convicted sex trafficker elaine
maxwell you were obviously making eye
contact when did you realize she was
sketching you
she had she was leaning on a piece of
paper and she took out a piece of paper
and she was going up and down looking at
me looking at me so i
you know i knew as she was sketching me
you could tell when somebody's sketching
you
and is it right i mean i don't know if
this is right but
weinstein asked for more hair
in one of your drawings he did he he was
walking i was sitting in an aisle seat
and he was walking out with his lawyers
and he looked over at my sketch and he
said can't you give me more hair
i just kept drawing and i did not give
him more hair
jane thank you so much for talking to me
and to our viewers today it's lovely to
be with you and i wonder how it does
feel to be the subject instead of the
one drawing and creating the work i
really hate it and that's why i don't
think cameras should be in the court
well no that would slightly put you out
of work but you've been in this line of
work for for more than 40 years
and i i just wanted to ask because the
the the clip that has gone or the image
rather i should say that's gone viral
recently
is of the now convicted sex trafficker
maxwell drawing you as you drew her
yes
that didn't make me nervous it didn't
make you nervous
no
sketchers are fine
i think if she took out a big fat camera
and put it in my face i'd feel a little
differently but was that not quite an
odd experience because i imagine that
doesn't happen that often
no that
it did happen to me
about 30 years ago when uh there was
there's a comedian named eddie murphy i
don't know if you know who he is heard
of him yeah definitely he did a little
sketch of me in in a court case he was
the defendant or he was actually suing
or some kind of dispute with his agent
and he was bobbing up and down and
sketching making fun of me you know like
pointy he did a little sketch of me on a
little post-it and he gave it to me and
i have it here in my apartment somewhere
i found it within five years i've it's
still here somewhere
okay so so once in 30 years it's
definitely not the norm no it's not the
norm so it was odd did you you were
obviously making eye contact when did
you realize she was sketching you
she had she was leaning on a piece of
paper she took out a piece of paper and
she was going up and down looking at me
looking at me so i yeah you know i knew
as she was sketching me you could tell
when somebody's sketching you
and it it didn't put you off
it it didn't really put me off but i
felt i better get this i better sketch
this because now this is what's
happening in the courtroom and i have to
draw what i see i was just going to say
i imagine that was pretty meta you know
you being drawn and her drawing you and
and and also do you think there's a kind
of is there a psychological element to
that do you think there could be a lot
of people are throwing in their opinions
about what it means and what it meant to
her what she thought she was trying to
like have power i don't i don't really
know
i don't read minds i can't figure out
what she was doing but i had to draw her
and i was really happy she was looking
straight ahead as you may be right now
because
a lot of times i'm seated right behind a
defendant and i can't see anything but
the back of their head so if i can get a
front view it's great
a lot of times photographers outside of
a courthouse will shout out somebody's
name as one when they're trying to get
their image just so that they get them
to turn front view so it was an
important thing for me and i i wanted to
keep it going as long as possible it was
great well that's interesting as well i
mean did you get to see what she drew
did she leave it on the table i did go
running out when i it was a break and i
went out and ran after her lawyer i said
can i see you know what i'd like to know
what was she sketching and she said you
know jane i can't discuss that with you
so i really don't know i never saw it
you're of course drawing as well
and and it has been a remarkable time
with the pandemic where you have a lot
of people's faces now obscured
with the mask how has that been um
it's partly easier and partly harder it
depends on who the person
glenn maxwell had great eyebrows and
eyes and good shape hair because that's
all i've got to work with it made it
harder for me to sketch because i use
pastels and i'm used to blowing some of
the dust off i'd be going but then it's
in my mask so it was hard for me to wear
a mask and work but drawing everybody
else in a mask
it makes it's not as interesting i'm
sure to to make a a portrait of somebody
with a
mask on but
i had to draw what i had to what i saw
well some have also felt you know it's
it's hidden people's faces at the time
where you do normally get certainly even
even going into the court some people
have felt you know it's um it's been
helpful to those who are on trial in
some way
i think it's been hard for
a defendant's team the lawyers to pick a
jury
because you can't see their faces it's
hard to read
you want to pick a certain type you know
when you're trying to select a jury
i think it really made it hard for the
them to
people look different when they take
their mask off i was working with a
reporter with a mask on and then i saw
them outside with no mask i had no idea
that was the same person no i don't know
i've had that exact same experience
myself quite a lot of times and i just
want to see and check that i've actually
met that person before
with that just with this particular
image because it really did captivate
people i know you're not actually on
social media um but this really did go
viral i know you can keep the images as
well that you you draw you submit um a
scan of them or you give a copy and then
you keep the original have you been
offered money oh yeah
sure yeah are you going to sell it no
i'm not selling it yet i have a
collection of 40 almost 43 years of of
sketches thousands of them and
there's certain precious ones that i
think are more important to me in my
collection to make it all worth whatever
and i don't know
i'm not ready to sell it um let it just
about something you were saying though
with gelane which is i think speaks to
your work is that you've got to draw
what you see and it's obvious that you
have had to take the emotion out of it
take my emotion out of it yeah exactly
because if somebody else shows emotion i
do have to put that in
if somebody's crying i have to capture
their emotion but i have to try to
not let my feelings go into the drawing
which sometimes i ha i do have reactions
on some cases sometimes i i feel like
i cry sometimes and
you know
tears are really bad for for pastels i i
just try to be neutral and journalistic
i've witnessed some horrific cases and i
see horrible crime scene photos
like i i just did uh derek chauvin case
i watched that tape over and over
because it was shown from several
different angles and it was really hard
for me to do that i had to i had to look
i had to look i had to draw it i
couldn't look away
people have an instinct to look away
from a horrific scene like that but i
had to really study the face
it was just horrible to watch somebody
die over and over and over
what impact has your work had on you in
in your life outside the court
i think
i do painting as well and my subject
matter is not crime and it's it's just
cityscapes of of just more pleasant
things i think
you know
i don't want to see or watch any crime
scene movies i i don't
i just need to escape it i don't touch
pastels when i leave court i only will
use oils at in my painting right no i
because i imagined some of what you've
been exposed to i don't know if it's
made you has it changed the way you feel
towards people do you sometimes think
about the worst things you've seen and
heard and maybe struggle to trust people
or think of the bad things people can do
i i try
people it's hard people's faces don't as
i've i was saying to somebody about
bernie madoff he looked like such a kind
old gentleman it would be so easy to
just fall prey to him and like give him
all your money and trust him you can't
really always tell by somebody's face
what they're really like inside that's
maybe something i've learned from
trials watching people you can't always
tell you there's a brilliant con artists
out there who just can mask
their true self and
just have to
be careful have you ever been frightened
in court
i was once i was sketching a group of
that i think they were the embassy
bombers it was a group of terrorists and
there were a lot of them and they sat
them all inside the jury box because
they had nowhere else to put them and
they let me sit in the well which is
where where the tables for the lawyers
would be
and i was sketching and one of the
defendants jumped out of the well left
over it was sort of like i think i had
just seen a tarzan movie with my son and
he left over with both arms took his
feet and started running across the
courtroom and the judge stood up and
pressed the panic button and the
marshals were standing in the back and
started running up and
tackled the guy against the wall right
next to me i it was terrifying i got on
the floor i held my pastel box i was
really afraid which is resting on a
little tripod next to me i did not want
that to go on the floor and i just
squatted down on the floor next to that
so that was a
pretty odd yeah well i mean if you are
regularly in the room with with big
criminals something at some point i'm
sure is going to go down that was the
time that it went down right and i had
never been allowed in
to sit where i was sitting again they
they always
then it was just a time when they just
were extra cautious since that point
about where they let anybody sit
what's it like sitting opposite
household names i'm thinking r kelly
and to an extent harvey weinstein okay
household names these are all sex
predators
so it's the metoo era of
a lot of the cases i've been covering
there's so many me too's
what's it like i don't know i think
they're they're all perverted in
different ways like weinstein
you know they all there's just i think
when people have a lot of money
power and fame it it corrupts them
and they're
they just become
deviants
and is it right i mean i don't know if
this is right but
weinstein asked for more hair
in one of your drawings oh yeah he did
he he was walking i was sitting in an
aisle seat
and he was walking out with his lawyers
and he looked over at my sketch and he
said can't you give me more hair
i just kept drawing and i did not give
him more hair you know well i imagine as
a as a woman and also someone who just
heard the details you just heard uh but
he's also still going to be someone
who's used to power
but that is not something you would
respond to pretty well
he's not going to have power over me so
i do not give him more hair
although
many many years ago john gotti did ask
me to like shave off his chin a little
double chin and i i did do that oh why
were you scared of him scared of him uh
it was
i don't think i was directly afraid of
him but
i and there were a lot of mob trials
back then in the 80s a lot of them
i was surrounded by a lot of
uh
mafia people back then
trial after trial after that was like me
too now back then it was the mafia
trials
commission trial
uh john gotti uh
the pizza connection trial there was
i can't even remember they went they
were constantly there were five
different families in new york and there
were
so many trials and they were switching i
couldn't even follow it anymore they
were switching power like gotti had
during the commission trial one of the
defendants there
vanished because uh gotti had taken him
out and uh
then he rose to power that was a whole
different era it's interesting that
there will have been phases like that
the mobs now me too
yes that seems to be the way the news
works it's not
i hardly i can't even think of a mafia
trial i had covered recently maybe six
years ago nobody seems to care anymore
now it's me too me too me too
there were finance there was an era of
financial crimes there was you know with
martha stewart and bernie madoff and
there were a lot of financial crimes for
a while and
and then and terrorist was a big theme
for a while and have you have you ever i
mean a lot of the people you've
mentioned um don't get out of jail some
of them will of course have you ever met
them in real life
once they get out of jail they probably
serve such a long sentence that i i
don't know i've never met them after
their trials that's i'm usually on to
the next trial how long do you have to
make the drawing that all depends on if
it's an arraignment
uh somebody during the boston marathon
bombing arraignment
he he was there for six minutes people
timed it i usually have no idea because
i lose track of time and everything i'm
just so arraignments go very quickly and
in six minutes i have to get as much
information down as i can and then flush
it out from my memory finish it up i i
can't obviously complete it in six
minutes but i have to have as much
information as i can get and sometimes i
have a witness the same witness on a
amount of trial they may be on the stand
for days the same person so i have a lot
more time i might do a wide shot with a
lot of people in it take my time i might
do
a wide shot a tie shot
it varies so everything depends on what
i'm covering that day
and how much time i've got and early on
i believe you drew one of the first
people to be executed by electric chair
in alabama when it reintroduced the
death penalty john evans
what was that like and how did it impact
you
it was pretty awful
this
the equipment malfunctioned the flames
came out of the knee pad they came out
of the helmet and i think they had to
redo it a few times
i felt i looked at around the you don't
see who pulls the switch and i look
around the room and nobody's you know
people are hands behind their back i
felt very responsible like i did it my
hands felt dirty and then i remember
driving home during a thunder and
lightning storm i had to go another hour
away
to get to where i was staying and
driving through puddles torrential
rainstorm and i felt like this is a
message from
the higher power and i felt like i don't
want to be part of murder i think murder
is wrong i don't think the government
should be doing murder and i don't want
to do it i don't believe in the death
penalty so that was that in terms of
those drawings that was the only time i
covered electrocution and yeah wow you
know there are other horrible things as
i just told you about derek shovin
trial that was pretty hard to watch and
and as i suppose being in new york as
well there's a particular as you've
described there's a particular level of
crime at times you know with the with
the mafia a lot of violence there's been
a lot that you've had to see and then
you also have the celebrities because a
lot of the time this is where this
happens well new york city is running a
violence going on all the time now more
than ever
even that's why i'm not plein air
painting on the streets of the city
anymore i don't feel comfortable
standing out there putting an easel up
and getting lost in an easel i don't
know who's going to come up behind me
there's a lot of emotionally disturbed
people
and there's a lot of violence and it's
just horrific and the city is changing
and
it needs to get fixed it's pretty bad
right now new york city so the trials
i'm seeing i feel safe i'm usually
there's a lot of
court officers or marshals or
csos standing around i feel like i'm
safe to draw there it's not like sitting
on a subway where somebody could get
angry if i'm sketching them nobody's
going to come attack me
you went viral again i mean maybe you've
been viral lots of times and you don't
know because you're not on social media
but there was also another time uh which
i think is smart a lot of the time um
because of your depiction of tom brady
the american footballer in court over a
cheating accusation people saying uh
that your picture didn't look like him i
mean that's not the same of course as
having art critics look at your art for
art's sake it's a kind of different lens
on it but but does that upset you does
that bother you
it did back then a lot but i think i
learned
i had a lot of emails and there's fans
who uh it depends on what team you're
rooting for
because some people love to sketch it
some people like how could i make him
look so ugly you know that you know i
didn't i don't tend to flatter people
when i'm doing quick courtroom sketches
well you i'd imagine that not a lot of
them look their best either it's their
day in court that's right they just come
in the fluorescent lights and they
get this over with get me out of here
have you ever been surprised by a famous
person coming in who doesn't actually
really look like you thought they would
i just at the moment remembered uma
thurman coming to court who's very
beautiful and she sat down with in the
witness box and
nobody would ever think this sketch i
made was her because you know she's not
looking glamorous and
i'm sure they've been a lot of these uh
i just can't remember them you've
mentioned around your your work and how
important it is to to capture what's
going on and for you i can tell it's
it's a very important part of the
justice system and transparency but what
do you say to those who think it's time
for cameras
well
as i said in the beginning i don't
really like being on camera i'm not
comfortable with it
i think it gives a lot of power in an
editing room to the media they can make
people don't when they see something on
camera they believe that's the truth
it's a photo they don't lie but there is
power in the way things are edited
things can be shown clips of certain
expressions that may not show the truth
once when the a sketch is shown i don't
think people have that oh this is the
truth this is where
it just captures a feeling of what's
going on so
i don't
i i think you have to watch out with
cameras in the court they may be quieter
now they're not as obtrusive they don't
make loud clicking noises anymore all
that may be true but
what is true what is the truth well i
mean your country where i am this has
been a big thing what is truth
post-truth era those sorts of things i
suppose it's one of those debates isn't
it and i'm interested as well as a
journalist because of transparency in
courts and and how we best do that well
courtrooms are open to the public
people are allowed to come in and watch
trials they're not
sealed off unless it's a sealed case and
if if if a camera's running
24 7
in the courtroom maybe that will give
more information but
tv news tends to
edit clips of what they think is
they the story they want to tell and if
the judge is yawning they may show that
and say oh he's not paying attention and
you know anything can happen
and i i think if
there probably are witnesses like me who
don't feel comfortable in front of a
camera yeah and also victims of course
as well
victims of course i can't even sketch
their likes as i'm not permitted
not permitted to sketch their face so i
have to
during
glenn maxwell and weinstein and
plenty of cases i i've had to draw face
featureless faces
right so i can i'd get the gesture maybe
the tears
hands hair but no
i can't really
i can't let their whole likeness show
where somebody could pick them out and
say oh i know and jurors i can't show
their face to especially anonymous
jurors i mean in the case of gillane
maxwell bringing it back up
a lot of people make a a big thing of of
what the person looks like when they're
found guilty
people want to read into that moment
don't they
uh do you draw that exact moment that
that response to the verdict i'm
watching what's going on and i if she
broke down crying yeah i would draw that
moment but she didn't really have any
reaction at that moment that i could see
is that quite common yes it's common
people don't always react maybe uh
they're in shock i don't know
yeah what a moment what many moments
you've been in in people's lives
recording
the biggest moment in many ways
often for the very worst reasons but
sometimes they they are exonerated as
well of course and that will be a very
important moment as well speaking of uh
mafiatraz the last one i did
he was exonerated and the courtroom
erupted with his fans like cheering yay
they ran out
celebrating so that's rare though
yeah
jane if you if you could do it all again
do you think you'd go into this line of
work knowing what you know about it yes
i do love what i do
i think i'm very lucky i i love drawing
people i'm very lucky i found a way to
earn a living doing it and feel safe and
i love it and i would do it all over
again yes well i've loved talking to you
thank you so much for for letting us in
and uh letting me and us turn the camera
on to you and focus on you for a bit but
we'll let you get back to focusing on
others thank you so much okay
and thank you so much for being with us
until we meet again take care
and goodbye
[Music]
you